polls are open for any piece to vote for  Tony Edwin my life is a courgette or as  I open my eyes on Wednesday in  Strasbourg one of these three movies  will be awarded the European  Parliament's 2016 Lux film prize a push  for a stronger defense policy with  conflicts on Europe's doorstep and  terrorism challenging its security  lawmakers called for a strengthening of  the e use military capabilities in two  reports submitted to the plenary air  pollution in Europe is a major health  issue many member states are falling  short of agreed standards MEP s will  adopt a new ceilings on emissions for  sulfur dioxide and other air pollutants  should negotiations continue or should  this stop the rift between Turkey and  the institutions and Brussels could be  widening mep s are set to debate a  resolution calling for a suspension of  turkeys EU membership talks